a lot of people watching right now are
like but social's not working for me and
i'm like the creative is the variable
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
all right first up we're kicking off the
show with shark
barbara corcoran her credits include
straight d's in high school and college
she had 20 jobs by the time she turned
23 and then she borrowed a thousand
dollars
quit her job as a waitress and started a
tiny real estate company in new york
city
that is now a five billion dollar real
estate business
welcome barbara hey my pleasure to be
here i love gary i'll do anything for
him
barb it's great to see you it's always
great to see you happy holidays
uh and pending new year we don't have a
lot of time so i'm gonna get right into
it because i know every
a lot of people were excited that you're
gonna be on the show so thanks for
kicking us off
in your opinion which consumer behavior
shift
will be key to driving growth in 2021
am i allowed to pick more than one
because i think there's probably four or
five out there okay
yes you are one the customer's in charge
i think if we didn't understand that
before we
certainly understand it now the behavior
that we
collaborate with the customer is over
with they're in charge
end of story so i think the key here as
an entrepreneur is you have to stay
very close to your customer and listen
hard and see what they need and i think
the first thing they need is they want
safety
and that ain't going to go away either
and when i say safety i think you have
to put safety first
customers uh demand it and you don't
have to worry about how to pay for it
because you can't afford to worry about
how to pay for it you just have to do it
i think social media is the fastest and
cheapest way to communicate
what the safety measures your particular
business has done
and i think the social discipline
protocols that we've
all recently encountered are here to
stay as well
uh things like the dots on the floor i
don't expect them to go away next year
at this time
mounted thermometers at restaurant doors
discretionary mass for travel
i think it's all we're going to just see
a softer version of the same moment
ain't going to go away but safety is
what
people care about now and they will
continue
how how long do you let me jump in on
that one uh you know
okay so we see a softening let's say a
year from today
do you think do you see a time where we
go back to 2019 levels or do you think
this is now
stuck in our culture for
quite a long time it's part of our
culture it's not going to go away
would you travel in an airplane whether
you're traveling business class or coach
and not wear a mask i wouldn't
never again i mean i kind of wanted to
do that when people were coughing next
to me but i thought it was socially rude
nope i'm going on the airplane with the
mess forever more i don't want to catch
what's going around
no nothing's going to go away totally
we'll have a residual that will become
part of our culture
definitely understood keep going okay
online shopping is king i mean i almost
feel embarrassed to say that everybody
knows that okay
but i think uh part and parcel of that
is you need to go to where the customer
is i have one business name cousins main
lobster large franchise
of lobster trucks yes i like those guys
yeah those guys i think you interviewed
yeah yeah a smart entrepreneur but the
moment
of covet hit that guy had pivot i hate
the word pivot but i'll have to use it
because i don't know what's the
substitute
he oh he turned his business around
there's a new substitute i can use
contactless pickup communicating where
his trucks are going to be
and he moved his trucks out of the
normal places that were crowded
and he utilized every single large
shopping mall parking lot
gave people numbers they waited in line
picked up they went home with their
dinner out
and his increase in sales went through
the roof within a month and a half
pretty sharp but he understood he needed
to go to where the customer was
comfortable being
i also have a business that's my most
successful business name comfy
and what it is is a wearable sweatshirt
and what they did is they had 150
million dollars in sales
in big box stores that were sent back to
the one cove it hit
because the big box stores they were
merchandising to had closed
what were they going to do they
increased their sales online
turned up a website that they hadn't
taken seriously
as before and they turned 150 million
dollars in sales
into 250 million dollars in sales they
went to where the customer wanted to be
that's exactly what they did
and then also again obvious so i
hesitate to say it
social media is the name of the game i
mean i don't invest in a single business
in the season on shark tank unless i
felt that the entrepreneur
was almost a borderline genius on social
media because i know we're going to have
to rely on the social media
platforms forevermore because we have
spoiled our customers with us
and they want it in social media i think
key traits or
or key entrepreneurs or pardon me key
employees that
all of us need as entrepreneurs are now
the producers the storytellers the
videographers
uh it's really become the new norm they
used to be extra people it was nice a
luxury feature if you want but with
social media being the name of the game
it's not the case anymore and barbara
real quick on that i'm trying to
interrupt um when you were building your
real estate
empire so much of it to do with branding
was direct mail a very strong pillar for
you
in the prime of your growth yes it was
but
uh everyone used direct mail but the way
i was able to
become extremely successful with it is i
used postcards
because i watched people at home
including myself and i didn't open junk
mail
right i was forced to read that's what
we used yes
so you paid you paid higher to be
your individual postcard versus maybe in
a value pack
and and you feel like even though you
were paying more to get into a mailbox
you were getting seen more often and
that gave you a leg up
it gave me a leg up but honestly i never
considered value packs because i'm so
too selfish i want my own stage wherever
i knew
and i got it on a postcard what was more
effective
uh than the postcard campaigns i
constantly ran was buying billboards 10
cents on the dollar
a lot of people remnant inventory right
inventory i did the same thing for wine
library new
front line and center billboards with
king and then also what a lot of people
didn't know then that i took full
advantage of is i bought remnant space
in the new york times in the wall street
journal
saved for retailers but when i checked
into their rules retail was not the rule
it was just
shop right and everybody was using and i
started putting full page advertising
for all my properties that looked at a
billion when i really had
10 cents on the dollar as well it's
funny i
i really think your career and knowing
it being an east coast guy
you know a lot of people think about me
with social media but i
i got my chops in direct mail print
outdoor radio
because because i was advertising as
like a kid from my dad's store
and i think the reason social was so
natural to me
was all the things i learned between
distribution under pr you just basically
talked about underpriced attention
you would buy more strategically around
places that people would look you took
advantage
of the remnant cost or the i did the
same exact stuff
on print and outdoor and direct not you
couldn't really do it the same way on
direct mail
but the other thing i learned during
that era because i was doing so much of
it
was the creative was the variable even
though i was buying
the full page new york times ad in the
dining section at a really good price
because i knew when to buy it and how
my ad mattered to how many people i
would get
and i think that that is a big a lot of
people watching right now
are like but social's not working for me
and i'm like the creative is the
variable
and the and the creative also must have
the key ingredient i'm sure you'd agree
with me
it has to be authentic people see
through the [ __ ] anymore you know if
you
if your story's not authentic if you
don't connect with them on some basis
i've even gotten rid of makeup in most
of my postings
i find that people respond better to me
looking ugly than all dolled up
authentic is key and i i don't think
that's going to change either of course
i agree with you you got one parting
shot we got a minute i know these are
going quick
okay so one more thing please you need
to be an entrepreneur that thrives on
change
i mean if you don't welcome change and
look for it seek it out like a missile
like
what's next what's next like a kid with
a curiosity box right
uh you're not gonna be ready for the
changes out there i mean change
for me and i don't think i'm imagining
is happening probably twice the rate it
would four years ago
and if you're not aware that today is
the single best opportunity you're ever
going to see again for the next 10 years
of taking over your competitors
marketplace his beat
because you can outperform outcreate out
do whatever you have to do to get rid of
that guy
this is the time to do it the best time
to move ahead is always in the worst
times any smart entrepreneur will tell
you they moved ahead in the worst times
because the big guys are asleep at the
wheel they get tight they get tough
most people go on defense
barbara it's great to see you okay my
pleasure thank you so much for this ten
minutes really
thank you very much youtube watcher
what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon